mm go enrichment is periodic ah welcome
back to more last of us I'm really glad
you boys wanted more of this I'm so
excited to give you more I was quite the
Terry episode and that's one the number
of confirmed deaths has passed 200 the
governor has called a state of emergency
thank you 200 yes we get some backstory
here while the title has spread
worldwide after relief report from the
World Health Organization showed that
the latest vaccination oh [ __ ]
for the bureaucrats out of power we can
finally take the necessary steps out of
the lightest city to be placed under
martial law my evidence are required to
report to their designated for lives
have continued for a third consecutive
day and winter rations are at an all
time
a group calling themselves the fireflies
responsibility for both attacks their
public charter calls for the return of
all branches of government
administration broke out following the
execution of six more alleged fire
execution still rise with us remember
when you're lost in the darkness look
for the light go to you the fireflies
what that sounds cliche is [ __ ] don't go
cliche on me Last of Us it's summer now
or maybe they just ride that to trick me
god damn I wonder what I dreamt about I
have some big old titties 20 years
[ __ ] later 20 years are you serious
he does humming it does look a lot older
but 20 [ __ ] here how was your morning
well I had a nightmare about big old
titties so there's no I don't soul early
don't you think she well you don't have
some interesting news for you
where were you Tess West End district
hey we had a drop to make what do think
why we had a drop to make yeah well you
wanted to be left alone remember so I'll
take one guess the whole deal went south
and the client made off with our pills
is that about right
huh deal went off without a hitch
my flash and cards to last us a couple
of months easy you want explain this I
was on my way back here and I got jumped
by these two [ __ ] all right yeah
they got a few good hits in they hit me
look I managed
give me that came through that these
[ __ ] still with us that's funny
that's found out who they were
yeah look they were a couple of nobodies
they don't matter what matters is it
Robert [ __ ] sent them Robert our
bomber he knows that we're after no
figures he's gonna get us first son of a
[ __ ] he's smart no he's not smart
enough we're smarter [ __ ] Robert I
know where he's hiding
like hell you do old warehouse in area
five can't say for how long now
well I'm ready now yeah oh I can do now
oh they're going for our Robert Ellis
what that's so weird that they jumped 20
[ __ ] years don't you think I think so
I didn't expect that it was that girl la
la la la la la she
sac sorry Billy Sullivan we got a few
hours left until curfew we better hurry
up then
so 20 years later and then you use the
ration cards yes football I've been
selected for outside work duties hey
guys gonna such crap soldiers are
supposed to handle it
they're running out of soldiers seek the
fire the free free the fedra and that
that is what is this so they sealed some
places off with cameras and [ __ ] and
surveillance
clients with all same personalities
mandatory look at that ration line
hasn't open yet
must be running a low again oh no wanted
keep an eye out
I bet robbers is on that list press I
bet robbers gonna [ __ ] think what did
they do it what are you doing hey can I
come what don't be mean what are you
sure yeah that's awesome for people who
sneak it out holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
they really build high walls huh damn
static up there are we going here oh
yeah we're going to area fight right to
get Robert that's enough of [ __ ] ice
for what is the text come in front I put
his eyes down hey guys I'll just play
cool
what's your business here at the day off
where's it in the frame what's up with
the subtitles we went through whoa
sighs scare the [ __ ] out of me okay oh
come on
all right we going I'm scared let's go
holy Sh a I bet I what's the matter
what's those [ __ ]
I got dami we were going there whatever
do now so much for the easy route wait
there's another route up all right
they're gonna teach me out of here
myself is that it
okay I can do this nailed it what am I
doing here
all right that's pretty cool they're
gonna close all the checkpoints [ __ ] at
5:00 right outside to pedal balls girls
go Ronnie outside or we could just let
Robert go cute haha ride bikes of
Jesse's a no-show I was there
hey he's tunnel looking I did though
it's clear I just used it no patrols so
where are you off to
gonna pay robber to visit you two really
looking for uh Marlene she's been asking
around trying to find it Marlene what
are the fireflies need with Robert I
think she'd tell me well what did you
tell her the truth
I got no idea where he's ID
yeah hey you stay out of trouble alright
military's gonna be out in force soon
yeah see you around
so the fireflies and us are after Robert
I don't think this is gonna end well but
that's is my opinion we should grab this
fire extinguisher leaned looking for
Robert what do you make of that sheep I
don't like it we better find him before
the fireflies do alright well we will
press we will I bet there that's why
they attacked or some [ __ ] like that
that rhyme not rhyme bros that rhyme
this place is sweet how's it going she's
stirring up out there how are we looking
over here I like a couch brown boy no
signs of military or infected that's
what I like to hear
yeh that's my boys Santa Claus coming
alright well this reminds me a lot about
half-life 2 these walls and the
quarantine and all that [ __ ] you bros
remember where's the [ __ ] is episode 3
icing oh [ __ ] what are we doing here
that's not really well-hidden if you ask
me with that alright see you later
hombre just gonna jump down there whoo
hi fault this place reeks whoa it's
gonna be Darth role way down here
I usually poop down here today what's
that grab our gear alright we'll be
doing that lady push forward ok no no
male let I'm a sneaky [ __ ] you
don't see me in the dark actually still
here from last time oh good where's
where's mine there it is
ok wow you just leave them like that not
hide him or anything a lot of ammo shot
scale they're just telling us that it's
a survival horror game and they will
give us not that much ammo which i think
is a good thing you shouldn't just be
able to pew pew you're way out of there
press r1 okay I got you I got it alright
- yup alright just hold still this will
only hurt a little bit just gonna give
you a face tattoo boost you up huh you
want to go up there is that it alright
come here lady you ready yes ma'am
pretty good hey guys ever heard of
ladders no in anyone come on no way you
can lift me up I'm too fat sorry you'll
have to go without me whoa she is strong
for carrying my fat ass that's pretty
cool that's pretty
there's gotta be zombie sabra's I don't
like this I don't like zany you gonna
like zombies none of us likes Amy
except that one be careful free ketchup
that a trick question is I been here for
20 years it's like wine ketchup it's
like wine has gotta be the most
delicious
ketchup ever whoa whoa they've been out
here in a while it's like we're on a
date nature really to cover our romantic
time got your way well she doesn't
really seem like the romantic type
either
she asked me but we do have a swimming
pool but maybe not today this is awesome
I like that there's got to be around
here somewhere first I thought is coming
weird with a 20-year jump but I think
it's kind of cool now where's the ladder
do I gotta find the ladder is that what
you're saying dupa dupa there it is oh
my got it got it right bring it over I
gotcha
kara does you want the ladder I am the
lot of giver provider provider and I try
okay I guess we put it here oh [ __ ]
ladies first lady you must be thinking
of someone else
it's all relative pretty sure she has
tits
anyway that's my criteria related right
there I'm just saying that's a good way
to know okay jeez what is this place
it's a piece of [ __ ] down through here
all right well okay what going Robert
still got our guns for his sake he
better once we get our merchandise back
it should be easy to unload
speaking of merchandise when's that next
shipment due wow that's a mo why do we
need guns and ammo should keep us busy
for a while
hold up whoa whoa whoa whoa what what of
you ladies first right haha god damnit
what is going on here hello
all these coming from place was clear
last time coming out of them coming out
of my [ __ ] there's your culprit the
[ __ ] is that
ah better keep your eyes and ears open
[ __ ] dicks growing on his ah what is
that it's like tiny fingers growing on a
why it's not that old what happens when
it gets old excuse me princess it
through here whoa
you okay yeah damn ceilings falling
apart be careful okay let's be careful
here buzz it's gonna be fine I'm just
gonna get through this area
[ __ ] watch it hey what what is that
guy doing nice
don't leave me turn haha okay fine fine
oh [ __ ] can i connect it's stopping him
in the head or something oh my god you
look prettier after so I got people
still died 20 [ __ ] years later huh
you think they saw the problem in 20
years but what do I know about things
not a lot obviously can't even aim at a
guy's face from [ __ ] two centimeters
away special Cola
oh there's em over there I saw em oh
there we go
sweet I like how he grabs it uh where
the [ __ ] are we going these things on
the walls are [ __ ] is disgusting
how about you tell me where to go lady
I'll be [ __ ] great
oh here special Cola got me what we got
here
well Robbo well Oh [ __ ] out what hold
to focus Joe okay
sneak up on the infected then grab them
by pressing what I was gonna [ __ ]
junkie oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] pigs I'm out
of here I'm out of here I'm out of here
I'm out of here I'm out of here
I'm out of here I'm out here I may hold
them
nice shot lady how is he not dead from
that okay I'm getting this one there we
go that's what I want it that one pretty
well yay let's get out of here please
all right that's all of them oh thank
[ __ ] god well cut back into the city
why oh yeah we're going to area five
those things [ __ ] girls okay
all right we're going I know nobody's no
one I shall do so fly whichever way that
wind is blowing whoa we're out we're
fine we're fine we're fine rust I went
pretty well I didn't choke him but we'll
get our chances later okay Mel's home
hardware that's a sweet-ass place can't
jump here whoa fresh air what do you
want
I hate the smell of that smell yes she
able to get you some of them air
pressures they weren't expired that'd be
a good idea
what do you mean lady well at least the
nature is beautiful you gotta appreciate
a goodnight where did lady go what are
you what are you doing I'm a hey we
almost got killed by zombies how do you
not care about this crazy girl I like
her I sure don't like the top Girling in
movies or games they always come off
kind of awkward my opinion like they're
trying too hard to be tough but she
seems cool would be a shame if something
happened to her sorry sorry what did she
say we got to find something well
there's a plank right there do I look
like I have a horns no I don't think so
but I guess I got a man's gotta do what
a man's got to do on all right let's put
you back up I don't know what can we
pass it to me you're just gonna take it
and leave me down here I J you better
not be [ __ ] me over with this lady
here you go
you better not [ __ ] up me over with it
it's bit heavy I think I can handle it
are you sure about that alright whatever
you whatever whatever you say lady how
do I get up I'm right here
okay why don't we just walk with it over
here all right sweet cakes
oh sweet Taliban very atmospheric IDF oh
uh al Alek make sure there ain't any
soldiers around I like that the game
hasn't made me cry
Claire come on like in the first episode
but I'm sure it will have its moments
but who knows these days she's not on
the cover of the game so that means
she's gonna die huh this is my critera
of everything I wonder what happened
with Tommy after 20 years shot it all
right Jesus Christ stop bossing me
around okay I know what I'm doing
and I know that Robert is [ __ ] gonna
die okay I'm taking it
whoa this chair is [ __ ] sweet what
happened what are you doing what are you
doing over here lady
hey little man you want some chocolate
no soldiers none of robert's man yeah
don't mind me really ruining my gun not
gonna do anything
what is this you know he's expecting us
I'll let him make it more interesting
whoa sweet-ass computers we could play
counter-strike good to go
okay good good hey guys we're not like
this how you doing today I heard you got
something now right now tears no it's
cookin to [ __ ] out of my woman now get
the [ __ ] outta work let's fry we're not
here to kill any Robert those doggies
can I have one of those [ __ ]
these dogs are all from ah let's not
hard
I don't know next week next week I will
try it's like I'm pretty sure we'll
return here for like version a hey don't
you buy it
Oh what if I touch your nipples it's
been a while
you don't visit us anymore let's try
how's that none of your damn business
Dinks oh I didn't [ __ ] think so
hey man looking at my ass is that it
didn't think so didn't think what are
they doing are you guys doing over there
idiots get a and you're going what do
you think you're going like okay I think
your talks didn't realize you two you
together go ahead we're not together and
awkward what are you doing playing by
yourself let's see what a [ __ ] hey guys
can we fight oh no we good don't ask
okay so where is Robby row where is he
where is he where is he oh we're going
here sorry you seen Robert yeah for
Robert you come through here half hour
ago
you went back to the wharf he's there
now don't make me come back here and
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up that's right okay lady
let's kill the Robert take his guns and
then die from the fire whoa are we gonna
kill people I don't want to kill people
that's against my will let us through
you guys need to turn around and head
back oh it's a nipple guy our beef isn't
with you we just want Robert you don't
want to do this yeah and the [ __ ] around
and leave now I'm not going anywhere
without Robert [ __ ] Oh bash your skull
unless you turn around and get your dumb
ass out of here don't call my betcha
[ __ ]
Oh take cover oh okay you ready no I'm
not
you just [ __ ] shot him get the angle
on them sorry but I gotta end this
episode here interesting interesting and
become curious how this will all play
out